Evet ben evet İzmir tarımsal Kalkınma
Kooperatifleri Birlik başkanıyım ilk
kadın başkanıyım ama benim içinde
bulunduğum Birlik Başkanlığı Aslında bu
kooperatif yapısı kırsalda tarımla
uğraşan hem kadının hem erkeğin bir
arada olduğu biri ama bu geleneksel atar
ki yapımızda ne yazık ki 1971'den bu
yana kadar kooperatiflerin bu yapısında
da kadın pek Başkan olmamış hatta hiç
olmamış yani 1971'den geldiğimiz 2024
şimdi tarımsal Kalkınma Kooperatifi ne
demek genellikle kır dediğimiz kırsal
dediğimiz alanlarda
ve tarımla uğraşan Kalkınma Dediğiniz
zaman kırsalda yaşayan insanların maddi
ve manevi olarak Vefa Ha doğru gitmeleri
ve bu kırsal kalkınmada kırsalda
kalkınan mı toplulukların Aslında
memleketin kalkınması ndan alacağı pay
bu paylar nedir istihdam olabilir yol su
elektrik hizmetleri olabilir sağlık
hizmeti olabilir eğitim hizmeti olabilir
ama öne en önemlisi her şeyi yapabilir
yemezsin tek başına bu çok önemli işte
orada Bu ülkenin kalkınmasında
alacağımız bir payda tarımsal örgütlenme
o örgütlenmede selam vermek El ele
vermek paylaşmak kooperatifçilikle mi mi
1931 lerde Mustafa Kemal Atatürk
İzmir'de Ticaret Odası'nın salonunda
şöyle
bu pratik kişilik tanım yapıyor ki
birleşmek de bu kuvvet vardır Hem maddi
hem de manevi olarak kuvvetlerimize zeka
ve maharet lerinizi geliştirmelisiniz
Ama bu birleşme bir kuvvetli ile bir
zayıfın birleşmesi demek değildir şimdi
burada kooperatifleşme Mustafa Kemal
Atatürk'ün Suriye'de gibi uçuk küçük
güçlerimizin zayıf olan seslerini
çıkaramamış tek başına Aslında bunun
altından kalkamayacak olan insanların
bir araya gelerek bir dayanışma
ekonomisi içinde ülkenin Cup zamanda
sadece o yaşadığı Kırsal alanda köyde
değil yaşadığı köyde kentte ve bunun
için kalkınması için çalışma yapma şimdi
bu tarımsal örgütlenmeyi Aslında en
basit 150 haneli bir köy düşünürseniz o
150 hanelik köyde Benim 30 dönem bir
Zeytinlik bahçem olabilir
220 bölümü zeytin içimiz Olabilir ama
ben tek başıma o zeytini toplayacağım
zeytin alacağım tüccara götüreceğim Ya
da sıkmak için uğraşacağım bunun
altından kalkamam kendimi duyuramam
kendini pazarlamak Zeytinli pazarlama
yağımı pazarlama nasıl pazarlayabilirim
o köydeki hanelerde yaşayanlarla
zeytinbahçesi olanlarda bir araya geldi
zeytin lerimizi birleştirdiğimizde bir
avuç zeytinin diğer köylülerle
birleştiğinde yani çıkarabilirim işte
kırsaldaki kalkınmanın en önemli paydası
arasal örgütlenme kooperatifçilik
uluslararası tanıda zaten Aynen böyle
yapılıyor ve bu Anadolu topraklarında
taahhüt zamanında bu zamana kadar
imecenin ne olduğunu gayet iyi bilmiş
Tam da bu Pantene zamanında Amerika'dan
Yeni Zelanda'ya işte kuzeyden günü
herkes aynı şeyi söylüyor dayanışma
içinde olma
bu güçlerimizi birleştireceğiz şimdi
bütün bilim adamları aynı şekilde bu
virüsle mücadele etmek istiyorum çünkü
biz tek başımıza ne Türkiye olarak ne
Amerika baş edemem Dolayısıyla bu
kalkınmadaki en önemlisi örgütlenme
Fakat bu tarımsal Kalkınma
örgütlenmelerin de 1971'den 2020'ye
kadar hiçbir zaman masada söz sahibi bir
kadın olmaması kadınların sesinin
duyulmadığı gösteriyor kadının tarımda
adı var kadının tarlada emri var ama
kadının sözü kadının sesi yok Ben de
İzmir Seferihisar'da oradaki Benim gibi
düşünen ve arkadaşlarımla beraber
ortaklarımızla beraber yola çıktı
sarımsak çocuk bir ondan sonra da bu
tarımsal Kalkınma Koop Seferihisar'daki
gücünün diğer İzmir'deki güçlerle
birleştiren bunda yönetiminde yer aldık
Ondan sonra da
bu seçimle geldim Aslında beni Seçen
oradaki erkeklerde İzmir'de Biraz daha
bunlara kolay herhalde ulaşabiliyoruz ve
bundan sonra kendi kendime dedim ki Evet
ilk kadınsın düştüm ama tek kadın
olmalısın bu tarımsal örgütlerinin
içinde kadınlarla beraber erkeklerle
beraber elele lan biz Çünkü İzmir Köy
popülerliğini olsa Kadın erkeğe limonlu
bir logo dur Fakat bu Ataerkil Yapı da
ne yazık ki kooperatif ortaklığına
Hadisenin kocam olsun arsanın tapusu
olacağı zaman kocanın üstümü dediğimizde
kadının bu tarz eğitimlerden haberi ol
kadının 12 yıllık eğitim zorunlu da olsa
kız çocukları İşte biraz geç
başlatılıyor biraz okuldan erken olur mu
kadın eğitimden ve uzak kalıyor O zaman
dedik ki demek ki herşeyin başı eğitim
tarımda da eğitim yola çıktık koptuk
geliyoruz dedik
yok ama bunu tabip Gene tek başımıza
yapamayacağınızı biliyorduk köy-koop
Hadi yapsana Bu kadar etkili olamayacak
İzmir Veteriner Hekimler Odası yla İzmir
Ziraat Mühendisleri Odası yla Ben bu
şekilde bir ekosistem diyorum hamurun
ekosistemi sivil toplumun ekosistemi
insanların da bir araya gelerek
bucakları ve ekosistem var Hep beraber
bir araya geldik koptuk Geliyoruz dedi
bir eğitim programı hazırladı Biz İzmir
köy-koop Birliği olarak kadınlara
kooperatif ortağı nasıl olabilecektir
kooperatifçiliğin Ne oldu köylere gittik
kahveleri oturdu kadınları çağırdık Bazı
yerlerde Evet kahvelere gelmediler biz
onların evine gittik hop aktifleşme
anlat onların eşlerin ortak olmasının
kendisini engelleme diyorlar Her zaman
da Veteriner Hekimler orada büyükbaş
hayvancılık varsa kadınlara büyükbaş
hayvancılık küçükbaş hayvan varsa onu
Neyi aynı zamanda topraklarımız rahatmış
bu aynı zamanda İzmir Büyükşehir
Belediyesi'nin Toplum Sağlığı daire
başka kadınlara bu tarımdaki ilaçlarına
kadar Aslında sağlığına zararlı olduğunu
eğitimlerle anlatmaya çalıştık Şimdi bu
bize şöyle dönüşler oldu toplantıdan
çıkarken kahveden bir kadın ya ben
hepsini yanlış biliyormuşum Aslında o
kadar iyi geldiniz ki bana ya da bütün
gün işte tarladan eve evden tarlaya
çocuk bakmış ya annesine bakmışım
kayınvalidesi bakmış ya engellisine
bakmış ama orada sosyal bir ortamda
Aslında en iyi bildiği şeyin yanlış
bildiğiniz düzelten tarıma da katkı
koyan bir kadın Dolayısıyla bu koptuk
geliyoruz projesinde çok inandığımız bir
proje oldu bizim kadınların bilhassa
bunlara çok ilgi duyduğunu gördüm ve
dedik ki hazırım bu kadar emeği varken
tarlada için kooperatif ortaklarımız
kadınlarla beraber erkekler oluyor
bu çalışmalarımızı devam ettiriyoruz
köye gidiyoruz İzmir Dokuz tane ilçesi
var Her ilçesinin dağında bayıldı ne
kadar köy varsa kadınlara uğraşmayacağım
ama